Simplicity and optimizing for Simplicity
when it comes to what you derive your
sense of meaning and happiness from in
life if you start there and then win and
[__] capture the entire world and I'm
the god of whatever the [__] industry I
care about that's a fantastic bonus on
top I don't think that this is the same
as setting your site to low and being
pessimistic I think it's reminding
yourself about
where you can genuinely derive happiness
from because although I take an
absolutely huge amount of Happiness from
the success of the show and the impact
of the show and all of the people that I
speak to the money is a derivative of
that and yes sure it's kind of like
being given a trophy you don't do it for
the trophy you do it for the success the
trophy is a derivative of the success
but
it's just a reminder that continuing to
believe I'm not happy yet
and all that I need is the next piece of
success in order to be able to justify
my happiness is a treadmill that for a
lot of people never ever ends and I do
think that it's important for them to be
reminded of it well absolutely that um
I'll be happy when situation
it may even be true
you may be happier when better things
happen in the future totally and you
probably will be but does that prevent
you from being happy right now at least
to the extent that you're capable and I
think a lot of people make another
mistake cognitively and they say things
like if I allow myself to be happy now
I'll lose that drive and to me I think
the best way to architect your drives if
you have any say in the matter sometimes
we're just automatons that are doing our
thing
is I don't like the idea of a drive for
Success that runs away from not success
that runs away from poverty that's never
again kind of thing I much prefer a
drive that is two-factor when it runs
towards more success and two it takes a
lot of Happiness from the Run itself
like for me total amount of net worth is
really cool idea like I have a certain
amount of money that's that's awesome to
think about but income streams are
fascinating and the growth of income
streams is fascinating I make more money
this month and more money that oh man
that's awesome and even more fascinating
is the productive effort that brings
those income streams that instantiates
them so I think a lot of people like you
totally rightfully indicate this save
their happiness sort of intellectually
for well later I'll let myself be happy
because I don't want to lose any steam
you can generate your Steam from the
positive sum game of doing your best
well that's that's where your steam
should come from think about it this way
and Alex told me this when we were on
the episode that the three most common
traits of high performing people Super
Rich High performers was a superiority
complex crippling insecurity and
maniacal Focus right so I got the first
two are interesting together yeah
precisely right so you have uh the
belief that you can do great things that
you're better than everybody else you
have a fear of insufficiency that drives
you to run away from something that you
don't want to become and you're able to
constrain your distractions so that you
run in a singular Direction without
wobbling all over the place
one of the things that that made me
realize is that
most of the people
that we admire the most have the least
admirable internal States so what does
it mean that the people who command the
most respect in terms of status are the
ones that you want to be the most
externally and be the the least
internally so this sort of Duality is
very difficult to deal with and the
point that you're bringing up here which
is
look
you are
almost in some regards momentum you're
built up you've got this degree of
inertia to how much personal development
and and skill set and drive it is that
you have
I believe truly that for most people
especially the people that are listening
to this you are already on the train
tracks to becoming something [__]
fantastic you're listening to content
that a rarefied strata of the entire
human history has ever been able to
listen to like literally the greatest
thinkers of your time get to go into
your ears as as frequently as you want
nominal cost yeah no cost yeah it
essentially for essentially free 24
hours a day and then you get to take
that and you get to change your life do
you understand how [__] insane that
is that you get to be able to do that
worrying and vacillating about the
outcome I believe gives you probably an
extra five or ten percent that all of
the concern all of the fear and the
numerouses and the sleepless nights
probably derives an extra five or ten
percent of outcomes because it will
cause you to be a bit more obsessive
which will be useful however
the other way to look at that is I could
get 90 of the outcomes and discard all
of the worry and concern and it changes
it from you believing that you're some
sort of driver in a car that needs to
frantically look for what direction to
like
ah this is ease I'm a competent
individual I am in control and as
opposed to being the driver in a car
desperately looking around for the sat
nav to see which way I need to turn
you're more like a passenger on a train
and you get to observe the scene as it
goes past the waitress comes by you
order some English tea you have a couple
of scones with with jamming cream and
you go oh this is a really enjoyable
process and the destination is going to
be arrived at in any case and I truly
believe that for a lot of people that's
the way it's going to work I have
something to add to that if you don't
mind
I think that the Neurosis the sleepless
nights and the worrying is a net
detractor from productivity and wealth
creation obviously it's a detractor from
proximate happiness
I think it's actually a detractor from
making you more money in in the future
and making it more successful and
becoming the person that maybe you could
be in your best case scenario I
just think that any amount of cognitive
bandwidth you spend worrying you could
be instead spending on solving The
Logical problems which the worry is sort
of maybe pushing you towards solving but
honestly it doesn't push you towards
[__] so for example let's say you work
in a certain space you're working a
certain business let's say it's
youtubing and you have uh there's a
topography about what you know concerns
are what your opportunities are Etc
now is do you need worry to stay at to
stay attentive to that topography if I
zapped worry out of your mind would you
just be like you're like hey man like
when is your next big podcast guest
that's going to take your next level
like look fine oh man who cares I I
doubt it as a matter of fact when you're
Serene and calm and centered you can
probably see more clearly what your best
path forward is and I'll debate this to
the gray if you're certainly more
productive in any Flow State when you're
calm and Serene and just just doing it
moving moving moving moving the [__]
Windows around on your computer or
whatever it is the kind of work you do
so the idea that this uh worry and these
sleepless nights somehow potentiate
success I think is the opposite of the
truth and I really do mean the opposite
of truth I think the most productive
people in this world are the people who
care okay the worry is not a holdover
for care worry is care expressed in the
wrongest possible [__] way if you
give a [__] you can be calm Serene and
mega productive if you worry that can
push you into Mega productivity but
again I don't understand is it worry
that surfaces concerns in your corporate
sphere no you're supposed to be
attending to those concerns anyway I
have never worrying about something has
done me zero good ever that I can ever
remember and boy can I [__] worry
Ashkenazi superpowers activate I can
[__] eye laser worry I can shoot a
[__] jumbo jet down with worry eye
lasers like uh you're just really
worried about the plane and the engine
catches fire like holy [__] that's
Instant Karma so directed linear Karma
it's um it it just a worry is a gigantic
[__] all waste of time and life and
energy and uh that's not a thought it's
not like if you ask chat GPT to worry on
your behalf it would be like what you
can actually help you with something
you're like well yeah yeah solve some
problems and it's like okay so what is
it I never really do understand where
worry comes from I don't say another
thing really quick I think the pop
understanding of how productive people
operate is that they worry thus they
work thus they succeed and in reality
it's they work thus they succeed and the
worry I think honestly comes along for
the ride in at least one major way is
because a lot of people that are
successful the high IQ or whatever the
[__] just happen to be Ashkenazi Jews
and as a holdover through Evolution are
also [__] worried all the time like
every [__] brilliant ashkenaz that I
talk to that's a [__] trillionaire or
whatever they're never like yeah man
thank God I worry they're like I [__]
hate this [__] I wish I wouldn't worried
ever the times in my life that I'm the
most worried are the times when I buy a
long shot the least productive and the
times when I'm the most Serene I'm
getting the most [__] done I'm being the
most successful I do not buy the premise
that worry is a potentiator I think it's
a distractor we both agree I think about
um some of the limiting beliefs around
victimhoods mindsets and I came up with
a concept that you have identified fight
but not yet named I think so this is
what I've this is what I've called
two-step potential Theory okay so during
an episode in your wacky ideas I mean
racist garbage are gonna spill for the
Jewish conspiracy here you see the
globalists they have this big octopus
okay so um during this episode with
Destiny who's a left-leaning streamer we
were talking about the difference in the
World review of people from the left who
focus on systemic problems and how they
hold people back and people from the
right who hope but anyway sorry go on
who hopeless on anything about systems
sorry people from the right who focus on
absolute achievement and how it can be
gotten there by the individual and this
is what Destiny said he said if I was
exclusively left focused I'd let my
restrictions Define me so I'd never
bother to do anything if I was
exclusively right focused I'd observe
how much further ahead someone else is
and I'd also give up shortly after
starting so he summarized his blending
of the two World Views together by
saying I'm going to work as hard as I
possibly can because I want to be the
best version of myself I recognize that
how good I can be as myself might be
controlled by some environmental factors
these environmental factors provide the
range that I can exist Within but within
this range my personal effort entirely
determines where I exist so I said let's
call this two-step potential Theory to
blending of individual agency with real
world limitations because your efforts
have tons of control over your outcomes
within the range that your world's
limitations will allow and I think I've
heard you talk about this too
um
I think that's very wise there's a lot
of truth to it something that seems
missing is
um what is your actual
ability in that regard how much talent
do you have
because you can achieve quite a bit of
success working just a little bit if
you're Mega talented
and a lot of the reasons why some people
do not achieve a lot of success isn't
because they're working hard and is not
because of environmental variables
because they're insufficiently talented
to
do as well as they want it to do so the
talent's a little bit missing from that
but if we interpolate Talent into that
Hardware into the range is hard work
plus Talent or whatever and then you're
in an environmental range there yes
every single morning for over three
years now I've started my day the exact
same way which is with element in Walton
element contains a science-backed
electrolyte ratio of sodium potassium
and magnesium and it is the best
hydration drink that I've ever found it
tastes fantastic it's super refreshing
orange is just the most OP flavor in the
world it's absolutely phenomenal and it
helps to play a critical role in
reducing muscle cramps and fatigue it
regulates your appetite it optimizes
brain health and it helps curb Cravings
they're also the exclusive hydration
partner to Team USA weightlifting and
rely on by tons of Olympic athletes and
everyday High performers all around the
world also there is a no BS no questions
asked grief and policy where you can buy
a box completely risk-free and if you do
not like it for any reason they will
give you a refund during an unlimited
duration and you don't even need to
return the box that's how confident are
that you love it elements are giving
away a free sample pack of all eight
flavors with your first box if you go to
the link in the description box below or
drink lmnt.com
MW that's drink lmnt.com
MW what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
[Music]